so und dann haben wir diese woche noch
einen völlig neuen olaf scholz
kennengelernt in moskau überlegen sie
mal wieder spricht er mehrmals auf
offener bühne wladimir putin und der für
mittwoch fest terminierte dritte
weltkrieg ist ja zumindest verschoben
auch wenn im moment keiner so genau weiß
ob die russischen truppen wirklich
abziehen von der ukrainischen grenze
oder ob sogar frische dazu kommen
letzteres scheint aktuell leider
realistisch so oder so unser neuer
kanzler hat beim besuch in moskau
wirklich einen absoluten boss move
gezeigt sagte er doch zum thema
nato-beitritt der ukraine
eiskalt das ist kein thema das uns
wahrscheinlich in unseren ämtern
begegnen wird wieder so lange wir sie
ausüben ich weiß jetzt nicht wie lange
der präsident vor hatte im amt zu sein
aber ich jedenfalls habe dieses gefühl
das könnte länger dauern aber nicht ewig
einfach nur wow das war nicht nur mutig
das war historisch olaf scholz sie haben
ganz richtig gehört olaf scholz hat
einen witz gemacht mike drop mehr geht
nicht freunde ja über vier stunden haben
die beiden im kreml verhandelt an putins
inzwischen legendären xxl tisch die gibt
es übrigens inzwischen sogar schon bei
ikea das modell kritik aber das nur am
rande so jetzt ist ja die spannende
frage wie kriegt man einen echten dialog
mit russland noch irgendwie hin trotz
allem wenn klar die ganze ost
erweiterung war im nachhinein vielleicht
nicht so pfiffig von der nato aber und
das ignorieren putin fans sehr gerne es
gibt halt schon so was wie ein
selbstbestimmungsrecht auch für kleinere
staaten für die ukraine zum beispiel mit
ihren immer noch erstaunlich tapferen
bürgern
wir haben schon vor nichts mehr angst
ehrlich ich zum beispiel gucke einfach
keine nachrichten mehr ich mache alles
aus hoffen wir dass putin genug verstand
hat und ist nicht wagt denn uns
beschützt unserer armee die europäische
union und so viele andere staaten
ja wie bringt man das der netten dame
jetzt schon bei ich versuch's mal so die
europäische union ist echt super drin
zum beispiel subventionen für steckrüben
zu verteilen aber andere länder
beschützen das ist nicht so unser ding
schon gar nicht vor putin der von einer
sowjetunion 2.0 träumt übrigens war die
mehrheit der ukraine immer klar gegen
einen nato-beitritt bis zur annexion der
krim 2014 will damit sagen putin hat
schon aktiv sehr viel dafür getan dass
nachbarländer heute in die nato wollen
aber reden wir doch mal über das rätsel
der woche warum haben amerikanische
geheimdienste den krieg für letzten
mittwoch vorhergesagt haben sie das
verstand warum so unnötig präzise am
mittwoch um 10 nach vier kann es
vereinzelt zu weltkriegen kommen oder
hat man genau damit den krieg verhindert
der russische eu botschafter versicherte
unterdessen dass russland betreffe werde
es heute keinen angriff mehr geben
kriege in europa würden selten an einem
mittwoch beginnen ja alte bauernregel
wer am mittwoch einmarschiert ganz
gewiss den krieg verliert natürlich
verhöhnen putins leute jetzt joe biden
us-geheimdienst ne man fragt sich woher
kam die info mit dem mittwoch ich kannte
ihn heute verraten tatsächlich hat die
cia wohl putins privaten
outlook-kalender gehackt und dann war
alles klar invasion am montag konnte man
ausschließen denn dabei valentinstag da
hat er alte romantiker dem pferd auf dem
er immer oben oben reitet blumen
gebracht dienstag ging auch nicht da
hatte sich wohl der sohn von angela
merkel selbst zum frühstück eingeladen
donnerstags krieg putin bekanntlich
immer ein liter frisches botox gespritzt
und freitag ist doppelkopf mit
lukaschenko assad und gerd schröder da
blieb halten oder mittwoch ist
eigentlich ganz schlüssig so eins ist
sicher meine damen und herren die
chinesen werden sich sehr genau angucken
was mit der ukraine passiert und wenn
putin doch noch rein geht und die
sanktion er locker wegsteckt dann sagt
sich präsident sie auf nach taiwan wenn
ich jetzt wandern denn tatsächlich macht
putin mit unseren sanktionen bislang gar
nicht mal so schlechte erfahrungen zur
erinnerung noch nach der krim annexion
hat deutschland mit ihm nord stream zwei
klargemacht 2015 obwohl längst zu
abhängig von russischen gas haben wir
gazprom in niedersachsen auch noch
unsere größten erdgasspeicher verkauft
ohne not natürlich hat er keine angst
mehr vor der reaktion des westens merkt
man auch im russischen fernsehen
jetzt neu bei rtl russland 7 sanktionen
sieben köpfe die besten russischen
komiker die noch nicht im knast sitzen
dürfen sich über den westen und seine
witze sanktionen
dieser schirm aus der box mit harten
maßnahmen
kann sie das jetzt ja auch in ihren
lebenslauf schreibt routiniert
ein problem für die die haben ja noch
lange atomkraft
kohle da ja auch nicht
den sanktionen sieben köpfe die lachgas
pipeline direkt in die wohnzimmer
der berühmte russische humor so und dann
hat putin einig auch noch die deutsche
welle rausgeschmissen aus russland aus
rache weil russia today deutsch bei uns
nicht mehr senden darf wofür die
bundesregierung aber wenig kann da der
propagandakanal hier nie eine lizenz
beantragt hat wir von der heute-show
fordern last rt deutsch trotzdem senden
ja erstens haben wir uns über die jahre
ohne ende lustiges material für unsere
sendung geschenkt zweitens auch andere
meinungen muss man aushalten ernsthaft
und genau deshalb sendet erste deutsch
ab sofort live aus unserer machbar
studio
russia today deutsch mit dieser flagge
ja wie schön dass ich auch mal ganz kurz
ein anderer perspektive zu wort kommt
wenn ich da komplett gebremsten ami
matratze wie ihn gar nicht zugetraut die
streaming immer
putin hat der ukraine
eingekreist ja warum denn hat aus reiner
notwehr
hat sich schon an zwei prozent der
russischen außengrenze angesagt wie sony
gierige alte kranke verstehen sie das
verstehen sie das nicht die nato hat
russland umzingelt von sorin schuh draus
keine frage der westen hat auch fehler
gemacht weil fehler hat der westen
gemacht
kann man denn die baltischen staaten in
die nato lassen nur weil gekleideter
panische angst vor russland haben oder
eines angeblich souveräne staaten sind
der westen muss endlich begreifen
solange putin sich nicht sicher fühlt
kann sich keiner sicher fühlen er will
die sowjetunion wiederholen sowieso und
dem osten deutschlands würde ich mich
auch nicht so sicher fühlen
also ich sag mal wenn es nur das ist
über sachsen können wir gerne reden herz
ja genau
das wäre noch der erst in dieser sendung
alles was putin macht macht er weil
seine sicherheitsinteressen ignoriert
werden das ist ein einziger schrei nach
aufmerksamkeit macht nach liebe aha auch
das mit der krim klasse beruf andere
länder an die teams der offenen hilfen
also sein dauerkrieg in der ost ukraine
die bomben auf syrische zivilisten die
sollten einmal die komplette
unterdrückung der pressefreiheit
ermordeten journalisten und
oppositionelle und dass er mit einer
handvoll kleptokraten den ganzen
reichtum russlands absaugt ja hilferuf
spreche ich hoffe so larsen machte alles
aus verzweiflung der westen zwingt ihn
dazu mit seiner respektlosigkeit wie
damals als die friedrich ebert und die
konrad-adenauer-stiftung mal besuch von
der russischen polizei hatten die
deutsche öffentlichkeit hat die
erklärung da soll eingeschüchtert werden
ich glaube sie schüchtern die deutsche
öffentlichkeit ein deine mutter
schüchtert die deutsche öffentlichkeit
ein warum kennt sowas in deutschland
eine fernseh lizenz aber wir nicht
ich meine man kann ja nicht im deutschen
tv einfach
news und absurden quatsch verbreiten
bzw man kann ja keinen sender
lizensieren bei dem politiker einfluss
nehmen
dieser flagge
[Musik]
mit dieser flagge
dieser flagge so längst ausgebrochen ist
übrigens der informationskrieg ost gegen
west wer schafft es sein narrativ
erfolgreicher in den medien zu
platzieren
der kollege friedrich küppersbusch ist
da wenn ich ihn richtig verstehe
mit beiden seiten nicht so richtig happy
irgendwer mit medien mit friedrich
küppersbusch
das einzige was putin noch besser kann
als manöver sind natürlich
ablenkungsmanöver also müssen wir sehr
genau hingucken und es ist höchste zeit
waren die goldene journalisten regel zu
erinnern audiard uhr et altera pars das
ist natürlich lateiner ist so ungefähr
bei audi gibt es alte teile audi kennen
sie das sind die mit der künstlichen
befruchtung bei sprung durch technik
sehen sie schon ist es passiert sie sind
abgelenkt leute aufpassen audiard uhr et
altera pars heißt natürlich höre auch
die andere seite das kann man noch mal
machen wir sind ausdrücklich gegen die
erweiterung der nato durch 0 mitglieder
im osten
sollte ungefähr dem pleistozän doziert
putin das in die ost erweiterung nicht
passt vielleicht hat er da sogar ein
punkt der bei ausgrabungsarbeiten am
mahnmal des unbekannten außenministers
wurde neulich dieser historische o ton
gefunden
wir waren uns einig dass nicht die
absicht besteht das radio verteidigungs
gebiet auszudehnen nach osten
spaß was man halt so sagt wenn man neben
dem us außenminister steht und gerade
voll bock auf die süße kleine ddr hat so
weit so klar und deswegen reibt man sich
doch schon ein bisschen verwundert die
ohren wenn es diese woche plötzlich aus
allen deutschen medien schallt was denkt
wladimir putin was geht im kopf dieses
mannes vor was will er erreichen was hat
putin vor niemand kann in seinen kopf
schauen was geht vor am langen tisch und
dem kopf des wladimir putin das ist die
milliarden rubel frage
jubel trubel heiterkeit nachdem putin
jahre lang an jedem poller getötet hat
was die dicke billiard kugel in seinem
kopf so rumpelt fragen doch jetzt
plötzlich mal was die dicke billard
kugel in seinem kopf und so weiter hier
zum beispiel fragen wir den russischen
nobelpreisträger und journalisten
dimitrij muratow wie war putin als kind
auf dem hof war er der anführer und man
musste sehr überzeugend auftreten wenn
man nicht verprügelt werden wollte ja
auch der presse auf die fresse in
russland verschwinden journalisten und
journalistinnen werden entführt
eingesperrt ermordet kein wunder dass
putin sich damit den westlichen medien
eine riesige fan kraut erarbeitet hat
wladimir so ich dir statt in
aussenpolitischen konflikt jetzt mal in
ruhe darzulegen und abgefahrene idee
vielleicht sogar nach lösungen zu suchen
wird nach herzenslust personalisierte
und draufgehauen auf viele junge
moderation gefreite hat die zugespitzte
lage eine wichtige wirkung im kern steht
dabei eben die frage nach
waffenlieferungen ab welchem punkt
liefern sie waffen helfen wir ihnen
dabei jetzt eben auch mit waffen waffen
liefern waffen uncle drohnen gewehre
haubitzen geben wir die jetzt frei und
waffen sprechen wir gleich darüber
nochmal bei den waffen soldatensender
powerplay das ist ja wohl richtig
gekannt bitteschön mit solchen bildern
konnte der russe wer so liebt zu werben
es kann doch kein schlechter mensch sein
ich hab's putin verschenkt den dicken
welpen weiter an angela merkel plus im
jahresabo wild und hund und dann friede
in unserer zeit
irgendwer mit medien mit friedrich
küppersbusch
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten einfach anklicken
macht's gut
los
hast du scheiße fährt haye